[Music]
in road rage news oh
submitted by bon me on my button
oh ban me the way steve says
oh my gosh
oh my gosh that's actually kind of cute
a woman was caught on tape smashing a
city bus in a road rage oh i see this
this [ __ ] was crazy dude what would it
with her car even that there was more
after that the crowbar yeah i pictured a
sandwich because we kept talking about
sandwiches yeah
so i just saw a big bag of bread that
she was [ __ ] up a car with really
stale ass like vietnamese ladies beating
up a bus with her baguettes stale ones
they hurt the roof of your mouth i guess
i don't eat but me because that [ __ ]
hurts you can actually get it with uh
with soft bread
i should do that
yeah so this
this woman she's an audi driver
she those damn audi driver like her
belly button sticks out yeah audi yeah
i'm a any driver then she has
wait don't you have an audi too not any
yeah you do not have any look no what's
this but you guys also have the audi the
car right oh and then she's about his
belly button
no i thought i was talking about his car
why would you know his smelly button i
was like what i was talking about i was
like when did you see his butt one i
know everyone sees his butt i thought
we're doing belly button identification
me too do you guys all have anything
throughout these
half any half audi okay you're a weirdo
gross it's a really weird belly button
what do you have a middle east okay here
i haven't eaten too i recently learned
that you have to clean your belly button
which is so gross oh god you didn't know
that before
wait toothpicks or q-tips
toothpicks oh no
ouch because mine's a deep inning and
you gotta really dig up in there like
i'm trying to [ __ ] scrape my
[ __ ] eyes i always wanted it in
like a deep inning oh i have a deepening
it's weird when you have like a when you
poke a tv but it like tinkles a little
bit like it's [ __ ] weird i cleaned it
i guess
i was i've always wanted to make like a
valentine's day card that says you make
me feel like when i poke my belly button
too deep oh i thought you're going to
say with all your good feelings it's a
it's a tingly feeling i like it you do
yeah it's like it's like oh
i don't like it yeah either that's a
sensation anyway so another so audi the
car
so she was driving that and then
she ended up getting to this crazy road
rage with this greyhound bus driver
because he she ended up like a
side swiping another car and then
somehow the bus driver got involved in
that so i'm going to show you guys this
video she goes off maybe because the bus
driver is doing this and pushed into
hurling causing her to push out
maybe yeah maybe that happened
ah this pool's like getting in i can
kind of understand where he's coming
from but he's like why would you stand
in front of a car don't do that since
playing wait why is he yelling at him
when he's on the floor he's just be like
bro let me like help you out real quick
i'm not gonna give you a [ __ ] leg
he's the ghetto superhero with low iq
yeah because i think that was trying to
hold the other girl back he doesn't know
what's going on he's just jumping in and
he doesn't he's not
he's like baby baby don't do that baby
calm down i'm like right superhero yeah
with [ __ ] low iq she's stupid
yeah it caused him more problems he did
because then the camera guy was trying
to restrain her which was perfect
damn dude she was having a bad day the
bus driver is stupid for standing in
front of me yeah that was stupid
he thought that he could stop like he's
like no he's just like you know what if
this [ __ ] hits me i'm gonna get money
and then you just you know i mean i
would have understood money from someone
that doesn't have money that's what i'm
saying only if it's like a corporate
like big bus i'd be like i'm gonna stand
here well she was driving an audi maybe
he thought it was like a shitty i think
as soon as you see the [ __ ] like going
in with the [ __ ] crowbar then you you
that's the moment they should be like oh
and then you just move away crazy thing
is she was destroying the bus but she
wasn't angry at the driver because if
you're that angry to [ __ ] up the bus
wouldn't you direct that violence toward
the driver yeah
she's [ __ ] nuts did she get arrested
yes so they did find her
stupid yeah they did a restroom i don't
know what i i feel like
i i would be scared to be in that
situation because everyone was so like
non-violent
toward that
you know what i mean i don't know like i
just watching it made me want to grab
both of her ankles and drop her on the
ground and stomp on her neck like it was
like oh [ __ ] what would i do like what
was the end game here yeah yeah you know
i'm gonna smash your windows and drive
off and what's the end game like you
don't think anyone will find you yeah
and now you got more stress on your
hands
well that's just when the animal comes
out and there's no more like it's so
primitive dude you know just these red
yeah i wonder if you're if someone's
gonna hit you with the car if you're
able to pull a gun out and shoot them
and not get in trouble
i feel like in certain states probably
in the south yeah you probably just
shoot them for
yeah
yeah i mean like um
if she has that weapon and she's coming
at you and smashing like you know you
could actually
do it oh the uber driver did you guys
hear about the uber there was an uber
driver and some truck almost hit him
like a big truck and he got out the car
and he's like what are you doing are you
not looking at the road i have a gun i
could kill you the uber driver takes out
a gun shoots him kills him on the spot
and it was self-defense whoa so i guess
you could shoot because he's saying you
don't know if he had a gun oh that's
broken okay
in i don't know if it's working so the
truck driver came out and
yeah i was like i have a gun but the
thing is he didn't even have a gun he
was just running like he was yeah don't
you have to be in active immediate
danger it's for self defense instead of
just but i guess if you say yes it
depends on the state do you wait pull
right yeah yeah do you wait till they
pull it out and kill you so
hmm yeah okay that's crazy oh he a man
who chased him in the truck oh he was
chasing him okay
well you know what um
as a weapon like if they're crashing
into you multiple times you can actually
shoot them because that's
you know salt with a deadly weapon yeah
yeah and it was in florida so he got
away with i just feel like california is
so dangerous to protect yourself like
you can't do anything to protect
yourself i want to carry a gun on me
seriously with the way everything is
right now it's wild i never thought i
would ever have i have a small one you
can have but uh i just want one for self
defense me too yeah next to my bed no
you do have one but i know like you have
cute purses
so the one i bought you i don't know if
it fits in your cute purses but this one
fits in your cute purses little tiny
bigger one and it comes like out of
nowhere too cause um we've been having
like a string of thefts at our apartment
complex oh no
those steal full motorcycles oh well
like guys
yeah they'll just drive in with like a
truck and they open up the back of the
truck and then they lift up the
motorcycle throw it in and they drive
off yeah and people's cars were getting
broken into and we have security we have
all that stuff yeah gated parking and
stuff it's gated even our even our
neighborhood do is just they'll just
like kind of wait until a car comes and
then they'll just drive in with them
yeah
and then when it's time to leave they'll
just wait until another car comes and
then they drive out with them too
with the motorcycle no no like the
person that has the thing because like
i mean if someone was waiting to decide
i would assume that oh the the thing's
not working or they forgot their it's
like a friend they're visiting a friend
yeah
really
i don't know you just never know right
like
has she been charged yet
uh not that i know what a loser it's
just that they did get her
because yeah everyone was filming her it
does look a little fun though i might i
have to say what does someone say it was
literally a gta player that's what i'm
saying like that's what i mean like i
mean like okay if no one got hurt
and if you could smash a buses window
and then throw that crowbar back in your
[ __ ] trunk and then drive off while
someone slides on your hood yeah she did
that's a new business we gotta jump into
then the smash uh smash land oh i've
always we're like with plates
there's rooms and then we have the
outdoor with buses with anger rooms you
can release your anger and i call it
smash land okay because i'm already
exhausted
well that exists but then this one you
get to drive a car yeah and you smash it
it's a whole land like disneyland
yes not just the room um what is it
demolition derby it's a whole land
yes and then i'll have paid actors that
piss you off so i'm gonna like survey
you i'm gonna say what pisses you off
your fiance stop bringing a jacket okay
and then yeah and then i'm gonna put you
in a room where it's really really cold
um why it's catered per person yeah
it's an experience
it's an experience and then they even
freeze the crowbar so you're like oh
i like that idea we'll find an actor
looks like your ex-boyfriend you can
beat the [ __ ] out of him yes i hate dory
mon can you i got your mom we'll get it
we should have one where um you're a
worker at starbucks and then a becky
comes along and wants to speak to you as
a manager and wants to complain
and then you can just [ __ ] them boom
but we'll employ like pro fighters and
stuff that can take a hit and all that
good actors
yeah so then they'll even if you punch
them yeah i mean i'm going to pay them
very handsomely because then like
they're putting their life on the line
you're also going to be charging very
handsomely absolutely because it's such
a catered and tailored experience like
it's just for you yeah the more detailed
it is yeah actually i like that yeah
yeah like i want to work and like make a
sandwich and [ __ ] and then like i want
somebody to come back and ask me if it's
gluten-free and i can toss that sandwich
in their face
or something or people who uh wanted to
return things after like six months yeah
and you can [ __ ] get that
chuck it at them so any customer service
job for you
[Applause]
i used to work with diamonds people
tried to return engagement rings because
of a broken engagement i'm like that's
not how it works it works it's not our
responsibility yeah
but they try so hard does it um
you don't take any refunds for jewelry
do you buy them back at all i mean uh no
oh well at least the places i worked i
know some places final right yeah
damn you better be also there's not
stigma if you buy a used engagement ring
why was it tainted yeah
it's first oh yeah i don't want
someone's badge to go to the pawn shop
exactly yeah just pawn it off the resale
value on diamonds are horrible yeah i
think it's like you buy for 30 000 you
sell it back for five bucks that's why
you should give your loved one 24 karat
gold so then they'll look like a gypsy
lover
i want a lab-grown diamond so bad me too
are they good are those good it just
depends on your preference so there's
different types of lab grown diamonds oh
my god i sound so educated i know yeah i
want to hear
lab-grown diamonds that are not diamonds
so they're like something cz moisenites
they over time they're gonna look cloudy
they're not gonna look like diamonds and
people who know diamonds can
automatically tell that you're not
wearing a diamond which is fine and then
there's lab grown which our diamonds
kind of recreated just sped up because
diamonds take millions of years yeah but
it's like in a lab and that is um it's
just personal preference some people
just like the fact that diamonds were
made naturally the sped up one and they
also like the idea of like there had to
be blood on this diamond yeah what do
you call that yeah conflict
diamonds
diamond oh that that's me
i'll be looking at like oh okay
this is not flawless it's got a little
imperfection but uh was it conflict
diamond yes okay i'm taking oh no
diamond yeah yeah i want the black
diamond when they tell me a child
soldier died for them oh
i want like one drop of an orphan and
all the diamonds i wear guys yeah like
how many people died to [ __ ] make
this
okay yes i want it
but there are some diamonds that aren't
marked up colored
oh
god i don't know anything about this
[Music]
huh
[Music]